All right.
The last time we talked about the historical Jesus and I talked about some of
the methodology that,
uh,
scholars debate about what criteria you use to figure out what in the gospels
might tell you something about the actual historical Jesus and what may be later
writing are myths or legends are additions of the Gospel writers themselves.
There's a very similar kind of problem with Paul and that,
uh,
it's rather debatable what we know historically about the historical Paul,
than what we find in different literary accounts with Paul.
There's a lot more to go on for one thing is I'll explain later today we
actually have,
uh,
at least seven letters from Paul that he wrote himself that most scholars
believe are actually authentic to Paul.
Uh,
then we have some other letters that are written,
his name.
We also have the traditions that are in the gospel of,
I mean the book of acts of the Apostles,
which you've read,
which talk about Paul and his travels.
So we,
there's a lot more material to go on with Paul,
but there's still quite a bit of debate about what is historical about Paul and
what is later legend or what is stuff that's just in some of the letters that
may not have been by him at all.
In fact,
if you remember,
we go back to the lecture we had to the very beginning of the semester,
one of the Times where we talked about what,
where does Paul go when in the book of acts,
where does he go?
According to Galatians one and two.
And at that point I tried to show that the two accounts of pause,
a back and forth between Damascus and Jerusalem,
the amount of time he spent in Jerusalem when he was there for how long,
who he saw,
who knew him.
All those different things that are presented in the book of acts.
I argued or probably not historical because if we've got Paul's own descriptions
of his movements and Galatians one and two,
uh,
it's much more likely we think that we have more accurate historical material
from Galatians than we do from acts.
But that's one of the places we would go is first to try to see what we've
gotten acts,
what do we have in his letters?
So this is a controversial thing to what I've said is Paul probably didn't spend
nearly as much time in Jerusalem as the acts of the apostles wants to make it
sound like,
uh,
I don't believe he started off his ministry in Jerusalem as acts makes it sound
to be,
there'll be other things about Paul that I'll talk about today,
uh,
from acts that I at least believe we should doubt whether they're historical or
at least we can't use them in any kind of dependable way as providing a
biography of the apostle Paul.
What does Paul though tell us about himself?
Okay,
first,
well,
actually let me say that that's not all there is with Paul.
There's a ton of more material about Paul that you have to work through in the
whole European tradition.
Paul has been thought of,
uh,
as the founder of Christianity.
Some people have said Jesus was not really the founder of Christianity.
He was a moral,
he went around and talking about different things.
Paul was the one who really founded Christianity.
He was the one who built churches.
He was one who came up with the dogmas and doctrines of Christianity.
He's the one who preached that.
What's the central central aspect of faith?
His faith in a crucified Messiah who's been raised by God and it's faith in
Christ.
It's the foundation of Christianity,
not what some might people say.
Jesus of Nazareth own faithfulness to God himself.
All of these things people have said makes Paul Moore the founder of
Christianity than uh,
than Jesus is.
In fact,
though,
Paul has been read in so many different ways throughout the last 2000 years that
people have even compared him to proteus.
Does anybody remember the Homeric figure of Proteus from the Odyssey?
Anybody who know proteus is this guy that is captured by a decease in his
sailors and they're trying to get a secret out of him.
So they hold onto him and he turns into different things.
He turns into different animals and he turns and they keep holding onto him
until he finally turns back into a man.
And then they can force him to give him their secret.
So people,
uh,
Wayne Meeks,
my predecessor in the chair I occupy here at Yale,
published a book in which it's just come out in a second edition in which he
talks about the apostle Paul and how he's been a represented throughout history.
And in his essay,
he calls Paul the Protean Apostle because Paul himself even says,
I have become all things to all people in First Corinthians nine.
So is Paul the kind of person who everybody makes out of him,
whatever they want to make out of them,
he turns into different kinds of things according to who's looking at him.
And that's exactly the way Paul has come across in many different aspects of,
um,
western history.
The early church,
for example,
didn't think of Paul as being so much the great theologian that sometimes he
became in later Christian tradition.
They certainly didn't think of him as their,
sort of the best Protestant apostle as he would become for Lutherans.
And for Calvinist,
Paul was mainly known as a martyr.
So in the early church,
when you see Paul depicted in art and in literature,
most often,
he's not depicted so much.
Uh,
as this great theologian,
he's depicted as the great martyr who is,
whose head was cut off in Rome.
So the Great Martyr Apostle is the early church's way of looking at him.
But then Saint Augustine and then following him,
Martin Luther,
they saw on Paul,
someone who is more like their own sort of psychological way of thinking about
themselves.
They saw Paul is this guy who was really trying to be righteous.
He tried to do everything.
He was a catholic monk,
and so he was,
he was trying to do all the kinds of things that the Catholic Church expected.
And he just became crushed under all the requirements of doctrine and ethics and
Christian and Catholic requirements.
And he finally,
he was,
he felt like I have to be perfect in order to be,
to be acceptable to God.
But no matter how much I try,
I can't do it.
I can't keep the law.
I can't keep the church's teachings.
I'm this total moral failure.
And so they read Paul as this person who experienced his life as trying to live
up to the requirements of God,
which they interpret it as the law and just found that you couldn't do it.
And this expressed for them a sort of universal human experience that all of us
feel when we try to live up to very demanding,
ethical and moral guidelines.
And we find out we can't,
we always fall short of what God wants us to do.
None of us is perfect.
We are always,
we're all sinners.
And so this idea that Paul represented this psychological,
uh,
struggling figure,
trying to be righteous and,
and trying to earn his righteousness by works.
And then all of a sudden discovering when he read Galatians and Romans,
oh wait,
we're saved by faith apart.
We're saved by grace through faith,
apart from works,
therefore works don't matter.
Therefore all the Roman Catholic requirements that we have to do this and that,
that that's not where salvation comes from.
It comes from simply your faith.
So this Paul then became the Paul,
not the ancient,
you know,
Christian Martyr Apostle.
So much.
But the Paul of the psychological discovery that True Gospel is you're saved by
grace through faith.
It's nothing you can do and therefore it works with the law don't matter with
you and God.
So the Great Lutheran Protestant Paul then becomes invented as this man who had
this psychological struggle.
And through this psychological struggle broke out through that,
into this,
uh,
discovery of grace,
the grace of God.
So that became this anguished guilt ridden Paul who discovers grace.
And that's been one of the,
the main figure of Paul that you get in Protestantism ever since Martin Luther
and John Calvin.
And as I said,
there are other people,
and even in the modern,
the 19th and 20th century,
who became worse than in history,
and they noticed that Paul Paul's letters don't sound like what you get from
Jesus in the gospels.
They just sound like different kinds of stuff.
Jesus was preaching the Kingdom of God was going to come.
Paul preaches Jesus as the King Jesus as the Messiah.
In fact,
people said the message of Jesus was about God and the kingdom.
By the time you get to Paul,
Paul's message is about Jesus himself.
So this shift of the proclaimer,
Jesus becoming the proclaimed in Paul that is Jesus being proclaimed by Paul is
one of the shifts that historians notes in the 19th 20th century.
So all of this stuff sorted or different ways of figuring Paul in history.
Um,
in fact,
one of the ways that people talked about this was Paul was actually the
corruptor of the Nobel pristine religion of Jesus.
Jesus was a great moral teacher.
He didn't care about all these Christian doctrines about the trinity and about,
you know,
hell and heaven and all this kind of stuff.
Jesus was just saying things like,
consider the lilies of the field,
how they grow.
They toil.
Not Neither do they spin.
And yet I say that it's Solomon in all his glory was not arrayed like one of
these.
I should be in a movie,
right?
Jesus of Nazareth at Yale
or you know,
so Jesus comes across sometimes as being this,
you know,
moral teacher who's floating around on boats and that'll sea of Galilee with his
disciples saying things.
Consider the sparrow.
And then Jay Paul comes along according to this reading and he turns all that
into this stuff about doctrine and hell and heaven and doing the right thing and
God's condemnation.
So for these kinds of people,
Paul was actually the founder of Christianity because he destroyed the kind of
message that the historical Jesus taught.
This is what you get from someone like Friedrich Nietzsche,
who wasn't that crazy about Jesus,
but he really hated Paul.
So Nicha said this,
this is Paul,
the corruptor of Jesus religion.
This is that kind of Paul,
the glad tidings,
that is the gospel,
the good news.
We're followed closely by the absolutely worst tidings,
those of Saint Paul.
Paul is the incarnation of a type which is the reverse of that of the savior.
He is a genius in hatred,
in the standpoint of hatred.
Nicha goes on to talk about Paul by making the heroic but unfortunate death of
Jesus into a sacrifice for sin,
which is what Nisha thought Paul had done,
nailed Christ to his cross.
That's what Nisha says about Paul.
The Cross was Paul's invention for Christianity.
And that's what made Christianity or George Bernard Shaw,
he has a great thing.
When I was at high school kid,
remember I told you about this?
I grew up in this very conservative church in Texas and I went to this big
public high school and I mean I'd gone to Sunday school my whole life and I
wasn't very well read in literature.
Well,
in high school we were reading some plays by George Bernard Shaw and we were
assigned,
I think mainly the play.
Uh,
and I was flipping through a bunch of George [inaudible] and I came across
Andrew cleaning the lion,
I think was the name of the play.
You know about the Andrew [inaudible],
the young man who finds the line with the thorn in his Paul.
He pulls the thorn out of the lion's Paul and then the lines very grateful.
And then years,
years,
years later,
Andrew,
please becomes a Christian.
And he's thrown into the,
into the lion,
until the lions in the Roman Coliseum.
And it just so happens that the lion who's thought,
who's Paul,
he cured is the one who's supposed to eat him.
And of course the line comes up and recognizes them and licks him and saved him.
And so Andrew cleaning the line is this story about,
you know,
the Christian martyr who say by the lion,
well that's the play,
but Shawl,
you always upended these wonderful introductions to his place.
And sometimes the introductions are more interesting than the plays themselves.
Cause this is where a Shaw who is a wonderful atheist and the beginning of the
20th century where he just lets loose and he just slams all kinds of political
stuff,
but a lot of religion,
he just really doesn't like religion.
So he in his,
uh,
I remember coming across into the library or something and here I was,
this pious little,
you know,
Protestant boy growing up in my conservative church.
And here's this guy,
very,
very smart in this introduction to Andrew plays in the lion explaining to me how
bad Christianity was really and how Paul had screwed the whole thing up.
It was kind of blew my mind.
You know,
was like,
took me days to get over this,
but George Bernard Shaw said this about Paul.
No sooner had Jesus knocked over the dragon of superstition than Paul boldly set
it up on its legs again in the name of Jesus.
So Paul is the one who makes Jesus's movement.
Superstitious are here.
He said this also,
Paul is the true head and founder of our reformed church as Peter is of the
Roman church,
the followers of p of Paul and Peter Made Christendom while the Nazarenes were
wiped out.
So the religion of Jesus,
according to Sean,
disappeared from the earth.
And all that we were left with is this shell called Christendom.
So all those things are Paul.
So we're going to talk about for the next few days,
we're going to talk about Paul,
both the authentic letters he wrote.
We're going to try to figure out who he was,
and then we're going to talk about how he was depicted by his own followers in
the Bible and then by some of his followers outside of the Bible.
What does Paul tell us about himself?
There are some important things,
but they're just a couple of details.
One in Philippians three,
five to six.
So Philippians three,
five and six,
Paul tells us that he was of the tribe of Benjamin,
so he even knows his tribal identity identity as a Jew.
He was a pharisee.
Now that surprises some people.
In fact,
Paul doesn't ever say I used to be a fair seat,
but I'm no longer.
He basically just called himself a pharisee that Paul's the one Pharisee from
priest 70,
uh,
Judaism that we know much about at all.
We don't know,
a lot of the rabbis of the Pharisees appear in rabbinic documents,
but those come from hundreds of years later.
Paul's one person who calls himself a pharisee and whose writings we actually
possess.
So Paul calls himself a pharisee.
He says that he was a persecutor of the church before he became a follower of
Jesus.
And he implies that this was out of zeal for the law.
So Paul started off as a very law abiding,
in fact,
zealous for the law Jew,
even to the point of being a pharisee.
And he says in Philippians that he was righteous under the law.
Now,
this is one of the reasons that scholars in the last part of the 20th century
started questioning this more Lutheran idea that Paul came to his knowledge of
grace because he felt like he couldn't keep the law.
I've tried to keep the law.
I just can't keep the law.
I've tried.
I just can't do it.
Well,
he tells us in Philippians that he actually was pretty righteous with the law,
so maybe Paul didn't have such a problem with the law after all for that reason.
Those are the things he tells us in Philippians in Galatians five 11 he also
says at one point,
am I still preaching circumcision
that just kind of hangs there?
Am I still preaching circumcision?
The one thing that at least tells us is that Paul at one time preached
circumcision was that maybe the reason that he was persecuting these followers
of Jesus is that some of them were not preaching circumcision or we don't know.
Now,
there are several other things about Paul that we don't get from his letters,
but that if you pick up most books on Paul nowadays at the bookstore,
they'd probably tell you these things about Paul's biography.
But these are things that we only find in the acts of the apostles.
And as I've tried to get you to see,
there are a lot of things in the acts of the apostles that we should doubt their
historicity,
especially when it comes to Paul.
So some of the things about Paul that people think they know about Paula's
historical facts only come from acts.
What are those one?
He was brought up and educated in Jerusalem at the feet of Gamaliel,
a very famous first century rabbi.
Well,
it's only an ax that Paul says that about himself.
Is this something that Luke kind of made up or put in there?
A part of tradition?
His original name was Saul.
According to acts,
Paul never tells us that himself.
It's not too unlikely.
A lot of Jews then as Jews now might have two separate names,
you know,
sort of their American named in their Israeli name or something,
their Hebrew name and their English name.
So maybe Paul did have two names,
but he never called himself salt in his letters.
That's a name that he's given an ax.
He also says in acts that he's a Roman citizen and that he was born a Roman
citizen.
That's pretty impressive thing for a Jew in the eastern part of the Metro
Uranian to be a Roman citizen.
And the first part of the first century,
that would have been fairly unusual,
but Paul claims that enacts but only in acts in acts,
Paul is,
is portrayed as speaking Hebrew fluently.
He gets it,
gets up in Jerusalem and gives a whole long speeches.
In Hebrew it may mean Aramaic,
but sometimes in ancient Greek texts they'll say Hebrew.
And what we think they probably were talking was Aramaic,
which is kind of a dialogue,
a dialect of Hebrew and Syriac.
So,
but Paul seems to be speaking Hebrew and ex Paul never in his letters gives us
any indication that he spoke Hebrew.
So did he speak Hebrew?
He seemed,
I would say Greek at least seems to be his first language and we don't have any
direct indication that he spoke Hebrew.
And then one of the things that's important for us today,
according to acts,
Paul's normal modus operandi,
his way of operating was to go to a town and go to the synagogue first.
And only after he was rejected in the synagogue would he then go preach to the
gentiles?
Do you remember?
This goes along with that ax theme that we talked about to the Jew first and
then to the Greeks.
So look with me because we're going to talk about first Thessalonians in a bit.
Acts 17 gives the account of when Paul first went to festival Anika,
at least according to acts now festival,
Annika is an important Roman city on in the,
in Macedonia.
That is the home area of Alexander the Great and Philip his father,
which is now considered by the Romans,
sort of proud of mainly the sort of the area that's ruled also with a Kia or
Greece.
It's a Greek speaking area,
but that's the one I get is a Roman kind of city.
It's,
it's romanized to some extent.
It's right on a major highway running east to west.
So it's an important place and here's the way acts describes Paul's getting to
Thessalonica.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm going to read this carefully because we're going
to then go to first Thessalonians and say,
can we confirm any of the acts material from Paul's own description about what
happened in vessel and not go after Paul and Silas.
This is x 17 one had passed through [inaudible] and Apollonia.
They came to the festival and Naca where there was a synagogue of the Jews and
Paul went in as was his custom and on three Sabbath days argued with them from
the scriptures explaining and proving that it was necessary for the Messiah to
suffer and to rise from the dead and saying,
this is the Messiah,
the Christ Jesus,
whom I am proclaiming to you.
Some of them were persuaded and joined Paul and Silas as did a great many of the
devout Greeks and not a few leading women.
Luke likes that phrase case.
If you read,
these are kind of he,
he likes to say that a few leading women also were converted in different
places.
It's more than one place he does this,
but the Jews I we see that turn that we've often seen an ax.
The Jews became jealous and with the help of some rough Ian's in the
marketplaces,
they formed a mob and set the city in an uproar while they were searching for
Paul and Silas to bring them up to the assembly.
They attacked Jason's house when they could not find them.
They dragged Jason and some believers before the city authorities shouting.
These people who have been turning the world upside down have come here also,
and Jason has entertained them as guests.
They are all acting contrary to the decrees of the emperor saying that there's
another king named Jesus.
The people in the city officials were disturbed when they heard this and after
they had taken bail from Jason and the others,
they let them go that very night.
The believers sent Paul and Silas off to Berea,
and when they arrived,
they went to the Jewish synagogue.
So they're arrested.
They have to post bail and then during the night they send them off,
get them out of town,
and they go to Berea.
And again,
Paul and Silas go first to the synagogue.
That's the account,
uh,
from x.
Now let's look though at first Thessalonians,
and let's compare a few things here.
First we're going to ask,
what does first Thessalonians tell us about several things?
How did Paul Work as a missionary?
How did he do this?
He was going around trying to convince gentiles to accept that Jesus of
Nazareth,
this guy they had never heard of before,
who had been executed by the Romans way off in a corner of the world in
Jerusalem,
that this guy was not only the new king of the Jews,
he had been raised from the dead and make king of the Jews.
But then now he's going to be king of the whole world.
And that even gentiles should be loyal to him and they should all become loyal
to the god of Israel.
Precisely because the god of Israel had raised this Jesus guy from the dead.
And therefore he demanded faith and adherence and worship from all the world,
even gentiles.
And that's so that's what he's doing.
He's going around to different towns and he's trying to plant little house
churches,
little cell groups in the different cities of the Greeks where he goes.
So here's what he talks about in first Thessalonians,
he gives this long thanksgiving,
Paul Sylvain Sylvain,
this is the Latinized name of Silas.
So we're talking about the same person that acts called Silas called Sylvania
here and Timothy to the Church of the Thessaloniki in God,
the father and the Lord Jesus Christ.
Grace to you and peace.
We always give thanks to God and then he goes on this long Thanksgiving about
their faith,
blah,
because our message of the Gospel came to you not only in word but also in the
power of the Holy Spirit.
Full conviction.
Just as you know what kind of persons we proved them wrong.
You became imitators of us and of the Lord.
In spite of persecutions,
you received the word with joints piper,
those Barrett,
you became an example to all the believers in Macedonia and a Kia.
A care refers then to the main part of Greece where Athens of course is,
and corn the other for the word of the Lord had sounded forth from you,
not only in Macedonia and a Kia,
but in every place.
Your faith in God has become known so that we have no need to speak about it.
So now here's the report that they're getting.
This has a few clues.
For the people of those regions that is of Macedonian a Kia report about us.
What kind of welcome we had among you and how you turned to God from idols to
serve a living and true God and to wait for his son from heaven whom he raised
from the dead.
Jesus who rescues us from the wrath that is coming.
That basically sounds like a little nutshell of what Paul must have preached to
them.
There's a wrath coming.
You're going to be distorting that wrath.
You can be rescued from that wrath if you turned to this Guy Jesus did we tell
you about who's the son of God and God raised him from the dead and you will
wait for him to come from heaven and he'll rescue you.
So that's kind of the nutshell of this message.
But notice who is Paul talking to here?
What kind of people were they before they became followers of Jesus?
Where are the Jews?
Is Paul talking to Jews?
This is not a trick question.
It's right there in front of you.
He's talking to gentiles because he says you turned from Gods to serve the
living and true God.
So these are clearly gentiles he's addressing.
So that's one clue about this is that Paul is addressing gentiles in First
Thessalonians chapter two verse nine he gives us another little clue.
You remember our labor and toil.
Now my translation,
I'm using the new revised standard version and in order to,
as I said before,
in order to make this translation usable for liturgical use in churches,
they've actually inclusive by some of the language.
So it says,
the Greek says,
you remember our labor and toil brothers.
My English translation says brothers and sisters,
but the Greek just says auto Foy,
which means brothers.
It can include women sometimes,
so it's sorta like the word men and older English when it was supposed to
include both women and men.
So the Greek Otto Foy can include women,
but it's just the masculine Greek word brothers here that's in the text.
That's not just a linguistic point.
I'm going to return to that later because I'm going to argue that there's
something important about this fact that Paul seems to address only men in first
Thessalonians.
Do you remember our labor and taught brothers?
We worked night and day so that we might not burden any of you while we proclaim
to you the gospel of God,
you are witnesses and God also so now one of the things to notice,
notice what Paul is saying.
He's saying that they themselves practice manual labor.
One of the things that Paul wants to insist is that he,
he didn't,
he and Silas and Timothy didn't live off handouts from the Thessaloniki.
He's insisting we owned our re earned our own keep.
We practiced our own trade.
What exactly was Paul's trade is again,
acts calls him a leather worker or a tent maker.
The word there in Greek is not exactly clear,
but some people have said that if that acts account is true than Paul May have
been.
The kind of person there was not a lot of tents you made for city dwellers are
some that they made awnings that would go these leather type in canvas awnings
that would go in front of shops and everything's to keep the sun off.
And they did make tense.
So if that's true and you and Paul was a tent maker or a leather worker,
that's the kind of thing he would have made.
But remember that's only an ax,
but at least here we get a definite indication from his own letters that Paul
was a manual laborer.
He worked with his hands.
He doesn't tell us exactly in his letters what he did,
but he's holding,
we did days we wouldn't burn you.
You are witnesses and God also how pure upright and blameless our conduct was
toward you.
Believers as you know,
we dealt with each one like a children,
blah,
blah.
Oh say so.
So they,
they practice manual labor when they were there.
And now look at Fort Verse 14 Chapter Two verse 14 for you brothers became
imitators of the Churches of God in Christ Jesus that are in Judea there in
Macedonia.
He's talking about the churches also in Judea,
for you suffered the same things from your own compatriots as they did from the
Jews who killed both the Lord Jesus and the prophets and drove us out that
displeased God and oppose everyone by hindering us from speaking to the gentiles
so that they may be saved.
Thus,
they have constantly been filling up the measure of their sins,
but God's wrath has overtaken them at last.
Now what's going on here is at least that Paul is saying,
you people in tests on like,
uh,
you received persecution just like the followers of Jesus did in Judea,
but who is persecuting these followers of Jesus in Thessaloniki?
Pardon
compatriots?
In other words,
Greeks,
they're not being persecuted by Jews.
They're being persecuted by their fellow Greeks.
So
they're experiencing persecution to once they've decided to follow this Jewish
Messiah,
but they're not experiencing persecution from Jews,
they're expensing it from Greeks.
Now you put all that together.
There is no mention of Jews anywhere in First Thessalonians at all.
In other words,
is pretty clear that Paul is addressing a church that's composed of all
gentiles.
They became followers of Jesus by turning away from idols.
They weren't Jews.
They're also experiencing persecution as the churches in Judea,
but they don't experience persecution from Jews.
They're experiencing persecution from gentiles,
their own neighbors.
Now notice how this doesn't fit the narrative of acts.
According to acts,
Paul goes first to the synagogue.
He preached to the Jews,
some of them believe including leading women,
and he started,
he saw he farms the nucleus of his group with Jews,
and then he adds onto that nucleus.
Gentiles.
That doesn't seem to fit.
First Thessalonians where there's no Jews mentioned at all.
The only people he addresses are gentiles and he says they were persecuted not
by Jews,
as is the case in ax,
but by gentiles.
So again,
Paul's letters seem to provide a somewhat different picture.
Then we got an ax and it's easy to see how ax told the story the way it did.
Remember over and over the acts of the apostles presents Paul in the same
pattern.
All the people in acts go to the Jews first.
They preach in synagogues first city after city.
They're rejected by the Jews or at least by most of them and then they go to the
gentiles later,
so it's schematic in acts.
In first Thessalonians,
we don't have a schematic history.
We probably have a much better idea of what actually happened,
which was that Paul founded this church with gentile believers and when they
experienced persecution,
it wasn't from the Romans and it wasn't from Jews,
it was from their neighbors so that we're going to come back to first
Thessalonians,
but that's just basically the set up that when we look at what's going on and
pestle and Annika,
we need to look at first Thessalonians and not depend upon acts again to tell us
the story.
Any questions about that before I go on?
Okay.
Other things about Paul?
Paul has this many letters in the new testament.
As you been reading in your textbook,
you've already noticed that Bart Ehrman talks about the undisputed letters.
There's just means.
These are the letters that almost all scholars will agree.
Paul wrote the disputed letters that is letters that scholars disagree about.
And then there are three letters that most scholars are agreed or not by Paul.
So the undisputed letters are Romans first and second Corinthians,
Galatians,
Philippians,
first Thessalonians and Phi Lehman.
Most of us reject as being by uh,
uh,
later disciple of Paul,
maybe even written in the second century.
Some people believe these are decades after Paul's death that these letters were
written a first and second Timothy and Titus.
We also call these the pastoral epistles because they show Paul trying to teach
Timothy and Titus how to be good pastors of a church.
It's Paul giving instruction,
so called Paul Given instruction to pastors of the church.
Now these letters is a lot more debate about,
I would say that I've ranked them here according to how,
how likely some scholars believe they may have been written by Paul.
More scholars will take from second Thessalonians is being by Paul.
A lot of us doubted
a few fewer scholars will take Colassians as being by Paul with more doubt on
that.
And then Ephesians is a letter is a different letter written by a different
person,
which use collagen's as a model.
And more people believe that Ephesians is not by Paul.
So in a rank of descending low probability,
second Thessalonians collages in Ephesians are doubted as being truly by the
Apostle Paul
the.
So let's,
that's just to give you what's going on here just for a moment.
And let me back up also and tell you before we turned to some particular texts
in First Thessalonians,
remember the lecture about the House Church.
And remember I talked about the Roman household structure and the patron client
structure.
Now this will be very important,
especially for your discussions as we come find Lehman.
Remember that the Roman household is a pyramid kind of structure with the potter
Familias,
the Roman head of the household at the top and that person's,
uh,
sons and daughters being next in the level the person's slaves in the household
being at the very bottom level,
but then above the slaves and below the sons and the daughters,
you've got people like freed persons of the householder who are,
who are become then the householders clients.
The clients give honor to their patron and the patron gives financial security
and sometimes legal help or other kinds of help,
social help,
social connections to the client.
And you might even have free people,
free men and women who have connected to different households even if they're
not connected legally.
Because in Roman law,
a freed slave,
the Friedman was even legally a client of the patron still owed legal duties to
the patron.
So it wasn't like the person who was freed became entirely free and footloose
and happy away from the household.
They still had connections,
both legal connections,
but apart from the League of requirements,
you would have even other nonlegal clients become like clients of a household.
That's we're going to see how different Char House churches start constructing
themselves.
Paul and his letters will repeatedly then address certain people by name and
greet them and he'll say,
and the church that meets in your house are in their house.
That's setting up that idea that the people he's named are kind of considered
the patrons,
the Potter Familia of the House Church.
And then the House Church has this patron client structure.
So keep that in mind when what we talk about this.
So now let's back up again and say now,
so what did Paul have to teach to the Thessaloniki?
Ans first he talked them mainly to turn from idol worship and polytheism.
Now this is hard for us to think about tape today because you don't go around to
almost any church and they have an altar call.
We had lots of altar calls.
My church,
you know,
they had songs at the end just as I am sung with like 75 different verses.
And they're trying to get you to come down to confess Jesus as your Lord and
Personal Savior and be prayed for and maybe be bad ties.
And you know,
they keep seeing the invitation song until you finally feel guilty enough that
you come down front for the altar call.
And yes,
the buses will wait.
The buses will wait,
come on down.
And almost no situation like that.
Are they saying you need to turn from stop worshiping Zeus and Apollo and
Artemis and turn to the living and True God?
Our Gospels today have other kinds of messages,
but apparently the most fundamental message that Paul was telling people when
you went around to these Greek cities was idols are not gods.
You need to stop worshiping these stones and rocks and things and start
worshiping the god of Israel.
The God of Israel is the only true God is the only living God.
All the rest of these are dead gods.
So that's the main thing that Paul seems had been teaching as he quotes,
they're in first Thessalonians.
Like I said,
he's teaching them to accept the god of Israel as their God.
He's teaching them to accept the kingship of Jesus Christ as God's son and the
Jewish Messiah,
to await the salvation of Jesus to come from heaven in the near future.
So yes,
Jesus is going to swoop down from heaven and Paul expecting this very soon.
And then to avoid certain gentile behaviors and he'd kind of,
we'll list sometimes things he calls gentile behaviors.
One of the most important of those gentile behaviors was sexual immorality,
or in the Greek,
simply the word [inaudible],
where we get the word pornography.
This is very difficult to translate into English because it could be used in
Greek simply for sexual intercourse.
A poor also was used for a prostitute,
but it,
but it didn't mean necessarily someone who sold a porn ages was a sex person,
a sexy woman,
or a sex man.
So porn,
a pornhub meant really basically just sex.
But June two Jews at the time,
it came to represent every aspect of sexuality that they believed were wrong and
that only gentiles did,
but they included a lot of things in this.
So adultery would be included in Porneia,
all kinds of having sex with anybody else,
but your married partner would be considered porneia masturbation.
It could be considered Porneia.
Homosexuality could be considered Porneia.
Uh,
having the woman on top with a man could be considered Porneia if the woman uses
a Dildo or something to penetrate the man that could also be pornea any kind of
oral sex,
whether it was homosexual or heterosexual,
any oral sex was considered Porneia by the Jews.
So porneia was as any list of things that Jews believed shouldn't be done and
that gentiles typically did.
And that's one of the thing Paul is very much against.
And he talks about that in one place.
Look in first Thessalonians four.
Now remember he's addressing here,
men who used to be Greeks and who thought,
who probably thought nothing at all about having sex with lots of different
people.
I mean,
you know,
the Greeks didn't seem to have many.
Of course women weren't supposed to have sex with me because the woman was the
possession of the man,
but they didn't care about men having sex with prostitutes or other men or other
women.
You know there when danger in that.
So he's talking to people who this was their idea of sex was that it's not that
big a deal for one.
Finally brothers,
and he's not saying sisters here,
the word his brothers,
and you'll see why as he goes on,
we ask an urge,
you in the Lord Jesus,
that as you learn from us how you ought to live and to please God as you are
doing,
we do so more and more for you know what instructions we gave you through the
Lord Jesus for this is the will of God.
Your sanctification that you abstain from Porneia.
It's translated in your texts maybe is fornication.
You just means any kind of immoral sex that each of you know how to control your
own vessel is the actual Greek and maybe translate his body,
but it means vessel.
So there's a debate among scholars is just talking about control your own body.
As a man or to control your woman,
who's the vessel for your sexual overflow.
Overflow in holding this and honor,
not with lustful passion,
not with desire like the gentiles who do not know God.
See Desire,
sexual desire and passion are linkedin.
Paul's mind only to the gentile world,
not the body of Christ that no one wrong or exploit a brother in this matter or
sister is not in the text.
You don't expect your book,
and the reason that makes them minimums is ancient.
People never thought about defrauding a woman by having sex with her husband.
They just didn't think that way,
but because the woman was the receptacle for the sexuality of the man and she
was polluted by having sex with any man except her husband,
to have sex with another man's woman was depriving that man of his property
rights.
So it made no sense to have it defrauding the woman here,
the sister.
It made perfect sense in Paul's mind to talk about defrauding the brother
because the Lord has eventually all these things for God.
Did Not call you to impurity,
but wholeness.
Therefore,
whoever rejects this rejects not human floated.
But God gives us the Holy Spirit.
Notice what Paul is doing.
Paula,
just like almost anybody else of his society.
He's talking to men here and he says,
you guys,
now you're in this new church,
this new community.
This is different from the way you used to live.
So you guys have your own mate and do what you need to do with her.
You know,
just control yourself.
Do what you need to do with her.
Don't go after the woman of your Christian brother.
Why?
Notice he says nothing about any concern for the woman.
There's he did,
at least in this text,
he shows no concerns for the woman's interest.
What he says is if you have sex with another man's woman,
you will be defrauding your brother.
You're robbing your brother of his right.
So that's shows this very traditional Jewish sense about Porneia sexuality that
Paul is expressing.
And you can see why he needs to say this because he's addressing this group of
guys who had all been Greeks now,
but what does he also say?
Look at for uh,
let's see,
five one through 11.
This is something else.
He seems to need to clear up with them concerning the times and seasons.
Brothers and sisters,
you do not need to have anything written to you.
For you yourselves know very well that the day of the Lord will come like a
thief in the night when they say there is peace and security,
then sudden destruction will come upon them as labor pains come upon a pregnant
woman,
there will be no escape.
He's talking about that Jesus coming on the clouds of heaven.
Now he's getting to what he did.
He alluded to it the first.
Now he's telling you how it's going to happen.
This is how it's going to happen and he's telling them,
you don't need to be.
He's reminding us of this,
right?
He already said,
you don't need to be told this.
I'm reminding of stuff you already know.
So this is stuff he's told them
but you believe it or not in darkness for that date as surprised you like a
thief.
You are all children of light and none of the day we are not of the night is a
darkness.
So let us not fall asleep as others do.
Others do.
But let us keep awake and be sober for those who sleep,
sleep at night,
those who are drunk get drunk at night,
but we belong to the day.
In other words,
he says basically stay awake.
Stay.
It's going to happen.
You don't know when.
Just be ready.
But why does he remind them of that?
Let's look back for 13 this is after he's talked about Porneia for 13 but we do
not want you to be uninformed brothers.
This is an art I grew up in that the King James version says,
we would not have you ignorant brothers,
which the men in my church like to say we wouldn't have you ignorant brothers
about those who have died.
Now notice now he's sending them something new.
This is not stuff they already know.
He's,
this is new material,
so this is not stuff he's preached them before.
Okay,
so that you may not grieve as others who do not have hope.
What he's telling them.
Don't grieve.
People in the church seemed to have died.
He says,
don't grieve.
Don't greet first.
Since we believe that Jesus died and rose again,
even so through Jesus,
God will bring with him those who have died for this,
we declare it to you by the word of the Lord that we who are alive,
who are left until the coming of the Lord.
So Paul believes that he probably will still be alive when Jesus comes back.
Will by no means precede those who have died for the Lord himself with a cry of
command,
with the archangels.
Call with the sound of God's trumpet will descend from heaven.
The dead in Christ will rise first.
This is not something he's told him before.
Seeing then we who are alive,
who are left will be caught up in the clouds together with them to meet the Lord
in the air and so we will be the wee bits,
the lord forever.
Therefore encourage one another with these words.
This is pretty astounding to me.
These people did not know what happened to dead people in Christ.
Yeah.
Paul hadn't told them that when he preached to them.
In Modern Christianity,
in fact,
a lot of modern religion in the west,
we tend to think one of the main things people become religious four is to live
forever.
Life after death to go to heaven.
What modern p Christians think salvation is his salvation from death or
salvation from hell.
Paul,
these people converted to this new group without having been told any of that.
What seems to have happened is that Paul converted them because he said,
Jesus will save you from this big apocalyptic coming wrath of God that's coming
upon the whole world,
so convert come to Jesus and he'll save you from that.
He'll rescue from that rep,
but what they seem to have thought was that while they were still living any
week now,
Jesus would come down,
he would destroy the evil people and he would set up the Kingdom of God on earth
and we'd have a new kingdom,
a new Ian that would last forever.
God would be ever over everything.
Jesus would be the king of the earth,
but it's not like it's going to happen in a thousand years from now.
They were all expecting to happen right now.
What they converted to was to escape the wrath and to live on into that kingdom.
They weren't expecting anybody to die and somebody in their community dies and
they go,
what?
Mary just died?
She's going to miss out on the party.
She's not going to get partake in the Pero CEO,
which is this Greek word that means the coming,
the appearing,
the presence of Jesus is the word here for the coming of Jesus,
the Pero Si of Jesus.
She's not able to participate because she died and Paul says,
way Babu had,
I forgot to tell you something.
You know that there will be people to die.
Don't grieve.
Now.
That's pretty radical thing in the ancient world.
You just don't go around telling people,
don't grieve over your dead.
Grieving is a big deal for everybody.
You're supposed to agree,
right?
Paul is so radical.
He tells him not to grieve and he says,
don't grieve because
if Mary is,
Mary's died.
But when Jesus comes back,
before we all get swooped up into the air to be with him,
the grays wall open,
the dead in Christ will rise up.
They'll all fly up in the air,
they'll meet Jesus in the air,
and then we'll fly up in the air.
We'll meet Jesus in the air and then we'll all come back down here and have the
Kingdom of God.
So don't worry,
the dead people won't miss out on anything.
But now isn't that curious that Paul has to fill in this big gap
in their knowledge,
the very thing that most of us modern people think you become a Christian for,
which is,
I don't know,
immortal life or the immortality of the soul or life after death,
the Thessaloniki is didn't know anything about.
They did some notes thinking about eternal life,
I think.
But I think what they thought was that if you are still living when Jesus came
back,
then you'd get to live forever.
But they were upset because people in their community had died and they didn't
know what was going to happen to them.
So Paul tells them this bit of information.
In other words,
what Paul had first told them was what would happen to them to,
to them.
When Jesus came back,
they would be saved from the wrath of God.
Now Paul has to write to them to say,
no,
don't worry if people in your community die because it's also going to happen.
But they won't get left out either.
And it gives us a very interesting sense of what kind of group this was,
that they didn't know something about Christianity,
the resurrection of Christians at the end of time.
This so much part of the creeds,
part of modern faith,
part of faith is the last few thousand years and these early converts to this
group didn't seem to know it.
So what kind of group is this?
Now I want to go back to the fact that I said over and over again,
Paul never addresses any women in this letter.
Now that it's not because he doesn't address women and other letters and other
letters.
Paul does talk to women even by name.
He talks about women's problems.
If you look in First Corinthians and we will,
we will when we get there.
Paul brings up this issue of sexual immorality again and there he talks to the
husbands and says,
you husbands,
don't go fill around with somebody else's wife.
But he also talks to the wives.
In other words,
Paul and other places,
when he talks to husbands,
he talks to wives also.
When he talks to men,
he talks to women.
He addresses women's problems in different letters,
but in first Thessalonians,
he never talks to a woman at all and he only talks about women when he's talking
about men trying to get to them con to control themselves sexually and what he
says to them is control your own thing.
Guys,
the Greek word translated body or vessel also means thing.
Screw us.
That's what Paul uses.
Their control,
your thing,
not as thing referred to his body,
his wife's body or as Genitalia.
It's anybody's guess and different interpreters disagree about how they would
want to translate it.
But what it certainly shows is that Paul's addressing a group of men and one
scholar [inaudible] Copenhagen has written an article where she says,
we've got to take this seriously at at least at this stage in Paul's career,
maybe he really did see these groups as being primarily male clubs.
Sure,
they may have had women,
you know,
and daughters and wives as part of them in a way.
But maybe in Paul's conception,
these things were sort of like fraternities,
the fraternity of Jesus.
And that's why he addresses only men and he doesn't talk about women.
And that's why when he's talking about,
and these are a fraternity that seem not to the expected,
the resurrection and all this other kind of stuff.
So Paul writes verse,
let's Odians to clue them in on it.
So what this would be would be a male club of Greek speaking,
gentile,
manual laborers.
They've now been initiated into a new group that demands adherence and loyalty
to the God of the Jews and unexpected Jewish Messiah.
In other words,
this is an apocalyptic Jewish sect of gentiles.
Now we'll see after spring break.
Yeah.
How some of Paul's other letters show that his churches,
if they started off like that,
they became a lot more complex later.
See you after spring break have you'll be talking about file Lehman.
A lot of the stuff we talked about today,
how's churches?
That sort of stuff may be important for your discussion groups.
This,
oh,
not this week,
right?
You're doing that next.
Next time we have class.
That's right.
This is not spring break.
Oh good.
We're good.
We can cover all this next time.